oh hi everyone welcome to another
episode of game life on this week's show
we took a field trip down to Microsoft's
annual spring showcase where we took a
look at some of the hottest games coming
to xbox live arcade games that you're
going to be able to download on your
xbox 360 starting this summer the first
game we checked out as soon as we walked
in the doors takes place in a little
town called South Park
oh I everybody look we found Glen
McKnight senior designer other ocean and
he's going to tell us about South Park
tenorman's revenge so South Park 10
revenge is Scott tenorman the evil
stepbrother of Eric Cartman has stolen
the boys xbox hard drive and is now
traveling through time with his army of
ginger minions to stop them from getting
it back the it is a four player
platforming game yes but tell me how the
South Park eNOS affects the gameplay so
I mean it's it's a 2d platformer south
park all the craziness but I mean we got
all the vulgarity all the language you
know this is an M title we have four ass
monkeys we have bollocks flies we have
six breasted chickens we have all kinds
of crazy things going on in this game I
think New Super Mario Brothers only had
five breasted chickens so you're
actually taking it up and on you're
definitely taking it up so tell me what
we're going with Matt Stone and Trey
Parker about you know how south parking
this game is so this game is super south
park ii i mean they they just kept
coming at us with new crazy ideas new
things to add in the game you know we
were we have mr. Hankey in the game and
next thing they know they're like we
need a poo choo train so you know that
so you basically spend an entire part of
a level running and jumping across a
giant train covered in poop and so like
this kind of stuff just keeps happening
all through the production you know is
like a DIN bollocks flies adding these
things it's like you know we need the
guinea pigs running around in Peru you
know those kind of things and the
dialogue that was written you know they
just the jokes my favorite joke in the
game is when Hartman says hey we're in
Mexico and they're like no this is this
is Peru and he's like Peru is in Mexico
dumbass you know it's that kind of stuff
that it's just really awesome and that's
why the game has an M rating is what
you're saying yes for sure so let's talk
about game play again cuz we're gamers
what's what's what's going on to it so
it's for its drop in drop out right like
Oh your friends can just join in it's a
drop in co-op game with your friends
online or at home you know and you all
get together and you feed on each other
you can brief each other as much as you
want or you can actually work together
and get things done when is it coming
out when are we gonna play it coming out
this spring South Park tenorman's
revenge Glenn McKnight thank you very
much
come have fun now back to me in the
studio now if getting up close and
personal with six breasted chickens and
forest frogs isn't weird enough for you
our next xbox live arcade game comes
from the twisted mind of Akira Yamaoka
maker of Silent Hill he's got a crazy
game about a baseball pitcher who
somehow ends up in a nightmarish
carnival
diabolical pitch is a new Kinect game
from the guys at grasshopper manufacture
this is the studio that brought us no
more heroes and shadows of the damned so
you know that it's going to be
completely insane and yes it is
completely insane you are a World Series
pitcher who has been transported into
some ungodly nightmare carnival world in
which in which horrible creatures in
cute fluffy animal costumes are coming
up to you and trying to do
god-knows-what to you and you have to
throw flaming and thunder filled pitches
baseballs at them and then you have to
kick them and then sometimes you can
raise your arms way up above your head
and do a diabolical pitch causing fire
to come crashing down on anything and
everything okay let's cook the roads one
thing that we as we're developing good
animal house cat or personal musical
game until I know dormant there's a sort
of bite-sized what am I please send the
money over at my channel I'll go get
that when we were dropping in quarters
at an art
Center and played for a few minutes so
we got the game over screen like it
gives you just that enough satisfaction
and like that excitement
your lives are gone so you have to score
on that next 25 and we feel like the
game play sessions that we design keep
the mind of creatine owning up to you
the little divine some good at all more
talking beginners emotional connections
but us we're never going to play another
Kinect game like this in your life it's
actually pretty fun and it's coming out
on April for wow those creepy rabbits
sure are creepy and speaking of creepy
the creepiest creepers of all creepers
are on their way to the xbox 360 in
Minecraft so we're here with Roger for
Microsoft who's going to tell us all
about minecraft xbox 360 edition so
Roger really uninitiated give us the 30
second elevator pitch but what is
minecraft ok so minecraft is a PC
phenomenon which is basically a sandbox
game with pixel art it allows players to
be creative it allows them to discover
stuff it allows them just to use their
imagination and just just do any create
anything they ever wanted and and have
an adventure while they're doing it so
let's say I'm one of the millions of
people who has sunk a whole bunch of
time into playing Minecraft on the pc
what is there on the xbox 360 to to
justify me getting into a whole nother
platform with minecraft well it's a
whole new platform but it also brings
for the first time ever multiplayer
couch play up to four player splitscreen
it also extends to eight player over
live so everything you're used to on
xbox live is also available in Minecraft
for the first time so what we're going
to be able to do is like have a party
friends you know four people sitting on
the couch in the same room all playing
minecraft all helping each other build
things basically correct you can have
four people on a couch in one house and
four people in a couch in another house
too so you can have two lots of
split-screen basically playing over live
what other advantages does sitting on
the couch playing with a controller you
know on the xbox 360 version bring to
the table right because you can see
what's going on all the time you can be
a lot more collaborative so you can say
hey can you go out and do that and
punched a person on the side of the sofa
for you and
and going to get the thing but of course
if you hate other people just want to
play alone you can do that too Costa can
yes and you can you can actually there's
there's more information in there right
and you don't have to keep constantly
looking at Wikipedia articles figure out
what it is you're doing yeah correct I
mean one of the things we try to do with
the xbox 360 version is to make it much
more approachable so you know there's
the the thing you're alluding to so we
had a whole brand new crafting interface
which takes every all the information
from the wiki all the ingredients all
the recipes and shows it to you gives
you information about it so every time
we find something it says hey you can do
this with it we've also extended the the
feature sets are now included tutorial
for the first time which just brings in
the people into the game faster so when
is minecraft xbox 360 edition finally
going to be on I will almost said on
shelves but it will never be on shelves
when will it be on the virtual shelf
that is the xbox live store it's gonna
be out in spring so not long now thank
you very much no problem thank you very
much minecraft is a big open world
first-person adventure but if you want a
little more structure a little more
puzzles in your first person games you
need look no further than quantum
conundrum it's the latest brainchild of
Kim Swift one of the designers of portal
my background is I've broken in the
industry back in 2007 with a little game
called portal and that was my first
foray into two games straight out of
school and since then I've moved on to
airtight games and making a new game
called Quantum Conundrum that sort of
has like a similar field of portal and
that it's a you know first-person
environmental puzzle game set in this
Victorian kind of manor home and you
places kid who has been dropped off at
your uncle's doorstep by your parents
they're like you know we want you to
just kind of be out of our hair for a
weekend so as you go into the manor
house you realize that something has
gone horribly wrong and your uncle
professor Fitzgerald quadrangle has gone
missing and now you're going to have to
find him luckily you have access to
what's called the interdimensional shift
device which is Professor quadrangles
latest invention that allows you to
switch dimensions on the fly at any time
so let's say I'm in this room right now
and I need to move a big heavy table
what I'll do is use my IDs device to
switch the dimension to fluffy dimension
and now everything is pink and cuddly
and cute but also it's useful to mention
because things are now ten times lighter
so i can pick up that table and throw it
across the room there's five different
dimensions in quantum conundrum there is
normal dimension there is fluffy
dimension there is a new one that we're
revealing right now which is heavy
dimension which is the polar opposite of
fluffy dimensions so things are ten
times heavier there is reverse gravity
to mention where everything that is
normally down goes up and then slow
motion to mention where everything is
now moving ten times slower than normal
so with that you're combining these
different dimensions in order to solve a
different puzzle as well as using those
dimensions in conjunction with gameplay
objects making different permutations
stuff you do Quantum Conundrum will be
coming out this summer 2012 on xbla PSN
and steam for pc as a big fan of portal
i am really looking forward to playing
Quantum Conundrum later this year well
from all of us here in the fluffy
dimension thank you very much for
watching check us out at wired.com /
game life or follow me on twitter at
colon heat